ما لفتنا الان في هذه الجوله هو تغيير
الرئيس التركي لمكان خطاب الشرفه الذي كان
عاده في مقر حزب العداله والتنميه في
العاصمه انقره لكن كما تشاهد وسادع زميلي
المصور يلتقط هذه الاجواء هنا في القصر
الرئاسي في العاصمه التركيه انقر حيث
نتواجد حيث جهز الفريق الفريق او معسكر
رئيس رجب طيب اردوغان هذا المكان داخل قصر
الرئاسي لخطاب الشرفه او ما يسمى خطاب
النصر وكما تشاهد كل الامور تقريبا كل
استعدادات قد اكتملت على ما يبدو ان هناك
ثقه كامله لدى معسكر الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان بان النصر سيكون من نصيبه في
الجوله الثانيه وبالتالي تم تجهيز هذا
المكان الذي نقف فيه داخل المجمع الرئاسي
والقصر الرئاسي في العاصمه انقره المزيد
من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات